ça s'il en a fêté en grande pompe cette
année le bicentenaire de la révolution
c'est le 20 novembre prochain que seront
signés aux nations unies la charte sur
les droits des enfants
une charte que la majorité des pays
signeront mais ce qui n'empêchera pas
certain de continuer à bafouer les
droits les plus élémentaires des enfants
dans le monde y est un cousin
l'association catholique des enfants
on a réuni plusieurs centaines pour
justement leur rappeler leurs droits
rené la teste et jean-claude 400
l'adulte à sa déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen depuis 1789
l'enfant lui aura dû attendre le
bicentenaire pour avoir sa propre
déclaration
les avoirs des droits ne suffit pas
encore faut-il savoir qu'on en a c'était
l'objectif de cette journée la formation
c'est de permettre aux enfants d'être
réellement partie prenante de la
convention des droits des enfants
ça c'est que c'est quelque chose qui
voter par plusieurs pays
on pourrait penser qu'on le vend pour
eux et là à travers ce qui est proposé à
cette journée ils peuvent dire leurs
droits et l'enfant est extrêmement
intéressé par les droites ottawa jeudi
le samedi puis sur les droits des
enfants comme ça on savait ce qu'il
fallait serrer par m
qu'est ce que tu as retenu deux mois que
des droits maintenant pas encore avec ce
jeu on a voulu que les enfants
s'expriment sur ce qu'il avait fait
pendant toute l'année sur les droits des
enfants mais aussi sur ceux qui vivent
tous les jours dans leur quartier à
l'école la famille droit de vivre
d'avoir une nationalité droit à la santé
à l'éducation aux loisirs aux jeux droit
à être différent en pouvoir choisir une
religion une croyance la convention de
l'onu
si elle est adoptée le 20 novembre
prochain sera un véritable prolongement
des droits de l'homme de 1789